Last time we started looking at the psalms and a number of different genres or
forms in which the psalms appear and we were just looking at a som last time,
which seems to explicitly reject the Deuteronomistic interpretation of the
national history in the national tragedy,
um,
depicting Israel as innocent and rebuking God for his inaction.
It was another psalm in this genre that I'd like to read from.
This is psalm 44 selective passages in God.
We glory at all times and praise your name unceasingly.
Yet you have rejected and disgraced us.
You do not go with our armies.
You let them devour us like sheep.
You disperse us among the nations.
You sell your people for no fortune and you said no high price on them.
All this has come upon us,
yet we have not forgotten you or been false to your covenant.
Very different from what the prophets have been screaming,
right?
Our hearts have not gone astray,
nor have our feet swerved from your path though you cast us crushed to where the
sea monster is and covered us over with deepest darkness.
If we forgot the name of our God and spread forth our hands to a foreign god,
God would surely search it out for he knows the secrets of the heart.
It is for your sake that we are slaying all day long and that we are regarded as
sheep to be slaughtered.
Rouse yourself.
Why do you sleep?
Oh Lord awakened.
Do not reject us forever.
Why do you hide your face?
Ignoring our affliction and distress.
We like prostrate and the dust.
Our body clings to the ground,
arise and help us redeem us as we fits your faithfulness.
So here's a som full of anger that contains an explicit denial of the
rhetorically inflamed charges against Israel that we read in in many of the
prophetic books.
We have not forgotten you.
We haven't been false to your covenant where our hearts have it gone astray.
We haven't swerved from your path.
Why are you behaving this way?
This astonishing,
uh,
protestations of innocence that accuses God a sleeping on the job is reminiscent
of job in a way.
The,
the two conflicting viewpoints that we see running through a lot of this
literature.
One in which there is suffering.
Therefore there must be sin.
Israel has sinned horribly and the other there is an explicit and explicable
suffering.
We haven't done anything that would deserve this,
anything at all.
It really is reminiscent of job.
It seems to give us these two perspectives on job's suffering as an individual.
Uh,
we see that now played out on the level of the nation.
One that is asserting in what we have here is a view that is asserting God's
negligence rather than Israel's guilt.
But then you can contrast psalms like 44,
the one I've just read and 74,
which I read at the end of the last lecture with Psalms 78 and one oh six,
uh,
these psalms belong to the category of hymns.
Some people call this category hymns in celebration of divine action in Israel's
history,
the sort of historical reviews that praise God for all he has done for Israel.
And they towed the Deuteronomistic line in their recapitulation of Israel's
history from the creation,
from the exodus,
and onto the conquest of the promised land.
They stress,
uh,
Israel's utter indebtedness to God.
Got his patiently endured,
Israel's constant faith faithlessness and so when you juxtapose these two types
of psalms,
they're just remarkably different.
He performed marvels in the sight of their fathers in the land of Egypt,
the plane of so on.
He split the sea and took them through it.
He made waters stand like a wall.
It continues.
He split rocks in the wilderness,
so it's a recounting of all the marvelous things that God has done,
but they went on sinning against him defying the most high and the parched land
to test God was in their mind when they demanded food for themselves,
they spoke against God's saying,
Ken,
God spread a feast in the wilderness.
True.
He struck the rock and water is flowed and streams gushed forth,
but can he provide bread?
Can he supply his people with meat?
It's interesting that this is in the third person.
They did all these terrible sinful things.
The psalm that I just read previously,
that protests,
Israel's innocence is in the first person we have not straight at all.
We've been completely faithful to you.
Why are you treating us this way?
So God's faithful actions.
Israel's faithful faith,
less responses are featured in the psalm that I just read.
And also in one oh six,
they tow the Deuteronomistic line.
And again,
we see this clear attempt to explain Israel's tragic end.
And here again,
the tendency is to blame Israel and to justify God at all costs.
Uh,
we'll move on now to the genre of psalms.
Actually these are sort of two genres that I'm putting together.
The genres of blessing and cursing,
obviously there,
um,
rather antithetical.
But these are psalms,
first of all,
psalms of blessing are psalms that invoke God to bless the righteous might be
the nation Israel or it might be the righteous within the nation and to punish
or afflict the wicked.
And again,
that can be enemy nations or it can be the wicked within Israel and other
nations.
And sometimes these psalms can be quite shocking in their violence.
Uh,
and in their fury,
psalm one 37 by the waters of Babylon,
I'm very rarely people read all the way to the end of that particular psalm.
Um,
it's very poignant at the beginning,
but at the very end,
it calls for vengeance on the Babylonians who destroyed Jerusalem verses eight
and nine.
Fair Babylon you Predator,
a blessing on him.
Who repays you in kind when you have inflicted on us.
Uh,
blessed blessing on him.
Who sees is your babies and dashes them against the rocks.
A Psalm 109 contains this very lengthy list of,
of terrible afflictions that the psalmist is asking God to smite his foes with.
That was a poorly constructed sentence that the psalmist is asking God to,
I don't want to say bestow,
but inflict upon his fo,
uh,
versus eight and 10.
May his days be few,
may another take over his position.
May His children be orphans,
his wife,
a widow.
And it's a nice way of saying,
man,
he died,
right?
May his children wander from there.
Hovels begging in search of bread.
May he be clothed the din a curse,
like a garment.
May it enter his body like water,
his bones like oil.
Let it be like the cloak he wraps around him like the belt he always wears.
May the Lord,
thus my accusers and all those who speak evil against me.
So again,
it's hardly the simple piety that we often associate with the book of Psalms.
And the last category I just want to briefly mention is a category of Psalms,
um,
that um,
have a reflective or meditative tone.
These are psalms of wisdom,
psalms in praise of instruction or Torah and meditation.
Um,
there are somewhat proverbial in nature.
Many of them will begin with this sort of stock phrase.
Happy is the man who,
so we said,
see that in Psalm one 28 happy are all who fear the lord who follow his ways.
You shall enjoy the fruit of your labors.
You shall be happy and shelf prosper.
Your wife shall be like a fruitful vine within your house.
Your son's like olives,
saplings around your table.
So shall the man who fears the Lord be blessed or reveres the Lord is the sense
of fear.
There.
Many psalms we've seen proceeded to presuppose worship in the temple,
um,
and can even have that.
And Tiffany [inaudible] character,
the call and response or call an echo character.
But there are three that I'm instead have this theme of Med meditating upon are
delighting in the Torah that some one,
Psalm 19 and psalm one 19 conveniently enough,
one night one 19 is the longest psalm because it's written in a cross stick
form.
There are different stands as a different stands,
uh,
for each letter of the alphabet at 22 letters and there are eight lines in each
stanza.
All eight lines beginning with that letter of the alphabet.
So it's a very,
very long some um,
and the Somme represents Torah as an object of study and devotion.
Studying Torah makes one wise and happy.
Psalm 19 verses eight through 11.
The teaching of the Lord is perfect renewing life.
The decrees of the Lord are enduring.
Making this simple,
wise,
the precepts of the Lord are just rejoicing the heart.
The instruction of the Lord is Lucid,
making the eyes light up.
The fear or reverence of the Lord is pure abiding forever.
The judgments of the Lord are true,
righteous all together,
more desirable than gold than much fine gold,
sweeter than honey.
Then drippings of the comb.
And so this elevation of Torah reflects a shift that begins or starts to occur
in the second temple period,
the late second temple period in which Tara is of growing importance.
And in about two minutes we're going to start to talk about this period and uh,
and the importance and centrality of Torah.
It's um,
it's centricity in terms of study,
uh,
and the study of Torah as a form of worship.
So there are many different ways to categorize and classify the psalms.
A many individual som seemed to combine units that belong to different
categories.
So for example,
you have psalm 22,
which opens as a lament,
my God,
why have you forsaken me?
That's the well known RSV translation.
And then it changes to a hymn of praise.
It concludes with,
with this it on into a kind of confident,
um,
triumph.
Um,
at least one psalm.
Psalm 68 really defies any kind of rigid categorization.
So we can't be too strict and trying to impose these forms.
They are helpful guides to the interpretation of the psalms.
But again,
we can't be too rigid about it.
But from the sampling that we've seen,
it should be in parent that the psalms are a microcosm of the religious insights
and convictions of,
of ancient Israelites perhaps because so many of them lack historical
specificity.
Some of them are quite historical.
Some of them in fact recount Israel's history in order to praise God.
But many of them,
very,
very many of them lack any real historical specificity.
And that is probably the reason that the psalms have become a great source for
personal spirituality in Western civilization.
Some of them were composed perhaps as many as 3000 years ago,
and yet they can be inspiring where they can feel relevant to contemporary
readers.
They can provide an opportunity to,
to confess one's failings or to proclaim good intentions or to rail against
misfortune or to cry out against injustice or to request assistance or to affirm
trust in divine providence or to simply express emotions of praise and,
and joy and wonder at creation or reflect on human finitude in the face of
divine infinitude.
I mentioned briefly,
um,
the centrality of Torah.
Actually,
no.
Let me finish talking about psalms and also move on to the other,
another major poetic work.
Then we'll come back to talk about the restoration period.
Um,
another poetic book within the Anthology of the Hebrew Bible is the little work
known as the Song of Psalms at Song of songs.
And for many people,
this is perhaps the most surprising a book to be included in the Hebrew Canon.
It's a beautiful and very erotic love song that celebrates a human sexuality and
physical passion.
The opening line seems to be a late superscription that attributes the book to
Solomon and it seems more likely,
however that these sent you was love lyrics are post [inaudible].
I'm the attribution to Solomon.
It was probably fueled by the fact that in first kings chapter four,
um,
we read that Solomon,
or there's a tradition there that Solomon uttered 3000 proverbs and 1,005 songs.
So it seems natural to attribute this song to Israel's most prolific composer of
songs and proverbs,
according to tradition,
the speaker in the poem alternates most often it is a woman.
She seems to be addressing her beloved.
Sometimes she addresses other women,
the daughters of Jerusalem at times,
the speaker is a man.
Um,
but he's not identified as Solomon.
Solomon's name is mentioned about six times,
but Salomon has not said to be one of the speakers.
And for the most part,
this,
the main speaker is,
is female.
There's a pastoral setting for the book.
The two young lovers,
um,
express their passion through an amid the beauties of nature.
There are frequent references to gardens and vineyards and fruit and flowers and
perfumes and doves and flocks of goats and shorn,
shorn use.
There are very vivid descriptions of the physical beauty of the lovers.
They are described and highly erotic passages.
Um,
translations of the song of songs vary tremendously.
as you might imagine.
So I'm going to read one little section from the translation by someone named
Walsh Ce Walsh,
which I think captures the,
the tremendous eroticism in some of the passages of song of songs I slept,
but my heart was awake.
The sin,
my lover is knocking open to me,
my sister,
my love,
my dove,
my perfect one for my head is wet with dew.
My lover thrust his hand into the hole and my insides yearned for him.
I arrived,
I arose to open to my lover and my hands dripped with myrrh,
my fingers with liquid maror upon the handles of the lock.
I opened to my lover,
but he was gone.
These poems are very unique.
They give expression to the erotic feelings of a woman.
Um,
and as I say,
translations will vary tremendously.
According to Jewish tradition.
Uh,
the ancient rabbis debated over whether or not the song of songs should be
included in the Canon.
And it was rabbi Akiva,
sort of late first,
early second century sage who's view prevailed.
He declared the whole world was only created so to speak for the day on which
the song of songs would be given to it.
Why?
Because all the writings are wholly,
but the song of songs is the holy of holies.
Um,
but for some religious authorities over the centuries,
the candid descriptions of passionate love proved to be too much.
And so the explicit content of the book,
which contains no reference to God.
By the way,
God is not mentioned anywhere in Song of songs.
Um,
so it seems to have been a completely secular poem.
Uh,
originally,
um,
the explicit content of the book has at times been interpreted away.
So not only do we have translations that,
um,
that tone down a great deal of the eroticism,
but we also have a tradition of interpretation that interprets away a lot of the
explicit content of the text.
So we have trends within Jewish tradition that read the book as a metaphor or an
expression of God's love for his chosen people.
Israel Christians have allegorize the song seeing it as an expression of
Christ's love for his bride who is the spiritual church.
And I think some,
I think,
I think all of the sections,
we'll be dealing with the song of songs this week.
So you should have a,
an interesting time looking at some of the interpretations of this text.
Now I want to move on a little bit more to the back,
the historical background of some of the books that we'll be looking at,
um,
in today's lecture.
And then also the last couple of lectures,
we left the Israelites in exile in Babylon.
And in five 39 BCE,
the Babylonian empire was itself a defeated by the Persians.
Under the leadership of Cyrus Cyrus of Persia,
five 39,
he manages to establish the largest empire that's been seen in the ancient near
east to date.
Uh,
it stretches from Egypt all the way north up to Asian minor,
which is modern day Turkey and all the way over to eastern Iran.
Huge Empire.
Unlike other ancient empires,
uh,
the Persian empire espoused a policy of cultural and religious independence for
it's conquered subjects.
Um,
the famous Cyrus cylinder,
this is a nine inch long,
um,
fired clay cylinder and it's covered in cuneiform writing and it tells of
Cyrus's conquest of Babylon.
Um,
the conquest is described as being at the command of Babylon's God Marduk.
So obviously the Babylonians,
God Marduk wanted our Cyrus of Persia to be able to come in and conquer,
um,
his,
his nation.
And it tells it his conquest and it tells of Cyrus is policy of allowing
captives to return to their homelands and to rebuild their temples and worship
their gods.
And this is consistent.
This archeological find is consistent with the picture that's presented in the
Bible.
According to the biblical texts we'll be discussing soon.
Cyrus in five 38 gave the Judean exiles permission to return to Jerusalem and
reconstruct their temple.
The exiles did return.
Many of the exiles returned.
They returned to what was now a Persian province.
It's the province of the WHO'd,
I don't think I wrote that up there.
You,
who'd is the name now of Judea and you who it is,
where are we going to get the word Jew?
You who Dee is the word Jew.
A one who belongs to the province of you who'd,
and um,
so many of the exiles returned to this now Persian province hood and they
exercise a fair degree of self determination.
Now,
periodization of Jewish history tends to center on these events.
So the period from five 86 to five 38 or so,
that's known as the exilic period.
Um,
most scholars maintain that the traditions of the priestly source,
the traditions of the Deuteronomistic source,
it pretty well re reached their final form in those years.
Obviously older traditions go into the composition of those,
those Corpora,
but they reached their final form form for the most part in that period.
So the post exhilarate period following,
um,
is also known as the Persian period.
I should put that there too
at first.
But of course the Persians won't rule for long.
Alexander's going to come marching through the ancient near east.
So after the Persians will have the Hellenistic period,
but the period after the exile is referred to as the Persian period,
the period of the restoration post exhilarate period,
it's also called the second temple period because by about five 20,
they will have reconstructed the temple.
So it's,
it's not an accurate really to refer to this time as the second temple period.
The second temple will stand until 70 the year 70 of the common era.
Um,
so the period of course before the exile we think of as the first temple period,
the temple is destroyed in five 86.
So the first temple period where preexist like period.
Now the books of first and second chronicles provide a second account of the
history of Israel.
Genesis all the way through second kings has given us one long account.
First chronicles actually begins with Adam.
Um,
and it does go through first and second chronicles do go up to the Babylonian
exile.
They echo a good deal of what we find in the books of Samuel and kings.
Um,
but they have more of a priestly bias and they eliminate a lot of material that
sheds a poor light on Israel's kings.
So for example,
you won't find the story of David and Bathsheba when you're reading the
chronicles account of the vein of David.
Um,
so chronicles is already and interpretation of,
it's an inner biblical interpretation.
It is the Bible interpreting itself right later strand of tradition reflecting
on earlier strands of tradition and re presenting that material in a particular
light.
The chronicler is less interested in David's political genius,
for example.
It doesn't go into his strategy and his political accomplishments nearly so much
as it does go into his role in establishing Jerusalem as a religious capitol,
implanting a temple in,
um,
organizing the music for temple worship.
These are the interests of the chronicler.
The book of Second Chronicles concludes with the decree of Cyrus a permitting
the Jewish captives to return to their homeland and build their temple.
We have a second fuller version of this decree,
which as I said,
seems to be consistent with what we know of Persian policies of the policy of
tolerating and even encouraging local religious cults.
So that fuller version appears in Ezra.
I'm going to read first from second chronicles,
second chronicles 36 verses 22 to 23 and in the first year of King Cyrus of
Persia,
when the word of the Lord spoken by Jeremiah was fulfilled.
The Lord Rouse,
the spirit of King Cyrus of Persia to issue a proclamation throughout his realm
by word of mouth and in writing as follows,
thus said,
King Cyrus of Persia,
the Lord God of Heaven has given me all the kingdoms of the earth and has
charged me with building him a house in Jerusalem,
which is in Judah.
Any one of you have all of his people,
may the Lord his God,
be with him and let him go up.
And then an as rhe there's an addition as or one verses three and four,
let him go up to Jerusalem that is in Judah and build the house of the Lord God
of Israel,
the God that is in Jerusalem and all who stayed behind wherever he may be
living.
Let the people of his place assist him with silver,
gold goods and livestock besides the freewill offerings to the House of God that
is in Jerusalem.
Notice that the decree at the very beginning and in chronicles and the second
chronicles version,
the decree is said to fulfill the word of the Prophet Jeremiah.
Now you remember that Jeremiah prophesied that the Babylonian exile would last
70 years,
right?
He wrote the letter,
he said,
settle down.
This is going to last awhile.
Plant plants and build homes.
So he had prophesied 70 years for an exile.
Well now from the time of the first departure of exiles and five 97 maybe to the
return in five 38,061 years,
it's close.
If you look from the destruction of the first temple,
perhaps in five 86 to the completion of the second,
somewhere between five 25 15 we're not really sure.
That's about 70 years.
Either way.
It seems that in the eyes of the Chronicler,
it was close enough.
This seems to have been a fulfillment of Jeremiah is prediction that it would be
about 70 years before they would return.
So the books of Ezra and Nehemiah give an account of the return of the
Babylonian exiles in the late sixth and fifth century.
And Ezra and Nehemiah were regarded as a unit.
Those two books were regarded as a unit in the Hebrew Bible,
um,
until the middle ages.
They may in fact have formed part of a larger historical work.
Ezra,
Nehemiah first and second chronicles Ezra.
And to a lesser degree,
Nehemiah seem to have a good deal in common with chronicles and therefore may
derive from the same author.
So sometimes in secondary literature you will see references to the chronicler,
which refers to the hypothetical author of first and second chronicles and Ezra
and possibly Nehemiah.
The chapters report the initial return of the exiles,
the rebuilding of the temple,
uh,
the career of Ezra and the career of Nehemiah.
All four of the books were probably edited in the late fifth century.
Bce may be close to the fourth century.
It's our best guests when Judah was a small province,
still within the massive Persian empire.
The books of Ezra and Nehemiah,
however,
contained conflicting information about the return,
about the restoration.
And as a result,
our knowledge of the timing of various events is quite poor.
It's really not clear who returned first to help,
um,
rebuild Jerusalem,
whether it was Ezra,
a priest or Nehemiah,
a scribe.
He was,
um,
uh,
Persian,
how describe it.
He was the governor.
Ezra was a priest and a scribe,
and Nehemiah is a Persian appointed governor of Judah.
And even though the chronicler dates events according to the year of the reign
of the Persian King,
the king is Artis Xerxes.
And unfortunately there are two kings named Arctic Searcy's in the fifth
century,
and there's one in the fourth.
So it's extremely difficult to figure out,
um,
when these events happen.
So keeping in mind that even the experts can not agree at all on the sequence of
events,
we're simply going to look at the career of Ezra,
the career of Nehemiah,
not going to claim priority for either of them.
And because the events are not presented in chronological order,
even in the books,
I'm going to skip fairly freely around between back and forth between the books
of Ezra and Nehemiah.
So the book of Ezra opens with Cyrus decree,
which we've heard,
and then provides a long list of the exiles who returned to Judah after five 38.
They're led by shish bizarre,
shish bizarre.
Uh,
and then among the exiles,
he says there was Yeshua who was a priest.
And Zerubbabel,
Zerubbabel was a grandson of King [inaudible],
who was the last Davidic king who had been kept in house arrest in,
in Babylon.
He had been among the exiles.
And five 97,
he eventually had been released from house arrest in and Babylon.
So now his grandson,
it was a rubella,
uh,
David died,
was returning to Jerusalem.
And you can imagine that this would have stirred a hope in the hearts of many.
Chapter three of Ezra describes the sacrifices offered on a rebuilt altar.
And the beginning of the process of rebuilding the temple,
uh,
probably around five 21 or so,
when the builders had laid the foundation of the temple of the Lord,
priests in their vestments with trumpets and Levi's,
sons of a soft with symbols were stationed to give praise to the Lord.
As King David of Israel had ordained,
they sang songs like stolen and praising the Lord for he is good.
His steadfast love for Israelis eternal.
All the people raised a great shout extolling the Lord because the foundation of
the house of the Lord had been laid.
Many of the priests and Levites and chiefs of the clans,
the old men who had seen the first house,
the first temple wept loudly as the site of the founding of this house.
Many others shouted joyously at the top of their voices.
The people could not distinguish the shouts of joy from the people's weeping for
the people raised a great shout,
the sound of which could be heard from afar.
So the older generations who remembered the magnificence of the first temple of
Solomon shed tears.
Um,
the younger people are shouting for joy at the establishment of a new temple,
but the building doesn't proceed smoothly.
And that's due largely to the hostilities of the surrounding communities.
And the surrounding communities are referred to as adversaries,
adversaries of Judah and Benjamin and chapters four,
five and six.
These,
um,
Samaritans in many cases,
uh,
offered to assist in the project of reconstruction.
Their offer is rejected and as a result,
the Samaritans and salted persuade the Persians that this is a bad idea,
right?
Rebuilding a potentially rebellious city is a bad idea.
And the Persians listened to them and they order the rebuilding stopped.
There are two profits then Haggai and Zechariah,
right?
So these are profits now of the post exhilarate period.
And we,
if as we go through our periodization of profits,
you'll want to add this fourth category postings like profits,
a third category.
They urged the continuation of the building,
uh,
a Persian official,
um,
objects the Jews appeal to the new Persian Emperor Darrius and they ask him to
search through the court records.
Look for the original authorization by Cyrus.
We've been authorized to do this.
And according to the text,
um,
Cyrus's edict is found.
Darrius agrees,
uh,
not only to enforce it,
but to honor his obligation to supply money for the rebuilding.
This is under Persian imperial sponsorship and he will honor the obligation to
supply money for the rebuilding and to procure sacrifices as well.
The temple is finally dedicated.
We think about five 15 BCE and a Passover celebration is celebrated in the
sanctuary.
There are other social tensions in the restoration community,
specifically French friction between those who had remained behind in Judea
during the [inaudible] period.
And um,
the returning exiles who,
although they were few in number enjoyed imperial support,
these a self styled children of the exile,
right,
they refer to themselves as the sons of the exile are children of the exile then
refer to the local people as the local Judeans as peoples of the land.
Um,
this is a derogatory term that seems to cast dispersions on.
They're very status as Jews there.
They're like the other nations or peoples of the land,
they seem to be classifying even Judeans in that category of other.
Um,
and as we will soon see,
um,
some radically different views of Jewish identity are going to emerge during
this period.
So that's the initial restoration,
the process by which the temple was rebuilt.
Let's jump now.
We think,
tell him where to the mid fifth century,
perhaps Nehemiah,
he's a Jewish subject of Persia.
He's the official Cup bearer to the Persian emperor arctic circus.
Cirque sees in the court at Souza.
This is a position that probably entailed his being a unit.
Um,
the book of Nehemiah opens with a description of Nehemiah's grief.
He hears these reports of the terrible conditions,
um,
of of his people in Jerusalem sometime around the mid fifth century.
And weeping.
He asks for the consent of the emperor to go to Jerusalem and to help rebuild
the city.
So Nehemiah travels to Jerusalem.
We think about four 45 BCE,
and he undertakes the reform vacations of the city and he meets with opposition.
And there's some internal opposition.
There's a female prophet tests no idea.
Uh,
in Nehemiah six 14 seems to be opposed to this and there's some external
opposition as well from Israel's neighbors.
The Samaritans,
the ammonites,
some Arabs,
um,
they resent this,
uh,
reconstruction and they see the reconstruction of the city's defensive walls as
an affront to Persian rule.
But Nehemiah continues.
He gives his workman weapons so that they can protect themselves against enemy
attack.
And the walls around the city are completed in record time.
These re fortifications helped to establish Jerusalem as an urban center.
And eventually Nehemiah is appointed governor of juice of Judah,
governor of Judah Persian domination.
The text says that he institutes,
um,
various reforms,
economic reforms,
social reforms.
He's seems to be trying to improve the situation of the poor and established
public order.
We think that the governorship of Nehemiah overlapped to some degree with the
mission of Ezra.
And Ezra is activities are reported in both the books of Ezra and Nehemiah.
Some scholars believe that they didn't overlap,
that that's,
uh,
an illusion created by our sources.
But Chapter Seven of the book of Ezra Introduces Ezra.
He's a Babylonian Jew.
He comes from a priestly family,
but he's also described as a scribe who is expert in the Torah of Moses.
And in verse 10 of Chapter Seven,
it said that Ezra had dedicated himself to study the teaching of the Lord,
so as to observe it and to teach the laws and rules to Israel.
So Ezra is commissioned by the Persian emperor,
um,
and in a letter and the text of which is,
uh,
represented or reproduced in Chapter Seven verses 12 to 26.
And the emperor commissions him to travel to Jerusalem to supervise the temple
and to assess how well mosaic standards are being implemented in the Gdn
province.
He's charged with appointing scribes and judges to administer civil and moral
order.
He has the backing of the Persian Empire to institute mosaic law as a standard
and norm for the community in Jerusalem.
And this is standard operating procedure for,
um,
for the Persians to find loyal subjects to regulate their own local cults
according to,
you know,
ancestral traditions.
And as there's work needs to be understood in that light.
Chapter Seven for you are commissioned by the king and his seven advisors to
regulate Judah and Jerusalem according to the law of your God,
which is in your care.
And you,
Ezra,
by the divine wisdom,
you possess a point magistrates and judges to judge all the people of the
province of beyond the river sees Jordan who know the laws of your God and to
teach those who do not know them,
but anyone who does not obey the law of your God and the law of the king be
punished with dispatch.
So he has powers of enforcement,
whether by death,
corporal punishment,
confiscation of possessions or imprisonment.
In addition,
as was appointed to bring treasures of silver and gold to the temple,
the text says that Ezra brings with him a copy of the Mosaic Torah in order to
regulate and unify Jewish life and the restoration community.
And together Ezra and Nehemiah bring about a revival as or as reforms are aimed
at strengthening the religious identity of the Judah Heights.
He wants to revitalize morale and he also wants to prevent the decline of mosaic
standards and to prevent the decline of,
of Biblical monotheism.
His two most important acts are the dissolution of foreign marriages.
This is a first and his renewal of the covenant.
Stay a little bit first.
The dissolution of foreign marriages.
Ezra is said to have been distressed when he arrived to discover that many of
the returned exiles had married with we think non Israelite women's not clear.
Sometimes peoples of the land might refer to Judeans who had remained behind,
but who themselves had perhaps become lax in as resides in their observance of
mosaic standards.
But they had married a women who seem to follow,
um,
pagan practices,
perhaps chapters nine and 10 describe his efforts to reverse this trend.
And he begs God to forgive the people for this violation of his law.
And then at a great assembly,
he calls upon all the people to divorce their foreign spouses.
Now this isn't in fact Penta to goal law,
plainly red.
Um,
the prohibition of marriage with any foreigner is a great innovation on as part
and it's one that,
as we shall see,
was not universally accepted at all.
Um,
the high incidence of intermarriage is perhaps indicated by the fact that it
took several months to identify all those who had intermarried and descend away
their spouses and their children.
Um,
even priests were among those who didn't view intermarriage per say is a
violation of the covenant.
And in the next two lectures,
we'll see other perspectives on this question of integration of foreign groups
within the community.
So I just,
I raise it as an issue now we're going to see many different attitudes as we
move through the last section of,
of the Bible.
The text of Ezra is prayer before God is a,
um,
a fascinating presentation of ezers interpretation of Israel's history and is
and prior texts and again constitutes yet another response to the calamity that
had befallen the nation,
but also constitutes another example of inner biblical interpretation later
levels or layers within the biblical text turning to older traditions and
interpreting them or reinterpreting them.
So listen to how Ezra understands biblical tradition and listen to how he
interprets Israel's history from Ezra nine.
He's praying to God before the assembled people from the time of your father's
to this very day,
we had been deepen guilt because of our iniquities.
We are kings and our priests have been handed over to foreign kings to the
sword,
to captivity to pillage.
And to humiliation as is now the case.
But now for a short while,
there has been a reprieve from the Lord our God who was granted us a surviving
remnant,
right?
Maybe the height,
prophetic idea of a remnant that would survive and given us a stake in his holy
place.
Our God has restored the Lester to our eyes and furnished us with a little
sustenance in our bondage.
Now what can we say in the face of this?
Oh our God,
for we have forsaken your commandments,
which you gave us through your servants,
the prophets.
When you said here he's quoting Bible,
the land that you are about to possess is a land uncleaned through the
uncleanness of the peoples of the land,
through their important practices with which they in their impurity have filled
it from one end to the other.
Now then do not give your daughters in marriage to their sons or let their
daughters marry your sons.
Do nothing for their wellbeing or advantage.
Then you will be strong and enjoy the bounty of the land and bequeath it to your
children forever,
right?
So he's quoting earlier tradition.
And after all that has happened to us because of our evil deeds and our deep
guilt,
though you are God,
have been forbearing punishing us less than our iniquity deserves in that you
have granted us such a remnant as this shall we once again violate your
commandments by intermarrying with these people who follow such a and practices
will you not rage against us till we are destroyed without remnant or survivor.
So as there's argument is first of all,
following the Deuteronomistic line,
you know,
history reflects God's judgment.
Um,
Israel's tragic fate,
um,
is because of her sins and indeed she's been,
she's been given a mercy and a reprieve.
She hasn't been punished as fully as she deserves.
He also follows the prophetic line that this remnant has been saved and now
restored.
So the covenant hasn't been completely abrogated,
but notice his identification of the sin for which Israel was punished.
Israel has mixed and this is the language that he uses elsewhere.
Israel has mixed in,
um,
whole has mixed holy seed with common seed by uniting through marital unions
with the peoples of the land.
Um,
meaning foreigner's cert.
Certainly,
but possibly also some of these,
um,
Judeans who had remained in the land during the exile and who seemed to have
adopted some of the customs of their neighbors.
And if history is any guide,
he's warning the community is placing itself at great risk by intermarrying
again and those who will,
uh,
intermarrying with those who will lead them into the worship of other gods and
the performance of important practices.
And surely he says this time God will not be so merciful as to spare even a
remnant.
So learn from history.
We send once by intermarrying that was a sin for which we have been exiled.
If we do the same thing again this time we will be punished without any hope of
a remnant.
So his interpretation of mosaic prescriptions about marriage,
um,
is an expansive one.
The Torah does prohibit intermarriage with the native Canaanites,
um,
at the time of the conquest,
the rationale being that they would lead Israelites into abhorrent pagan
practices,
child sacrifices and so on.
But of course,
it's actually not a completely,
uh,
you know,
there is actually a legal provision for what,
for how to go about.
I'm marrying a captive Canaanite woman,
so it's,
it's not a completely unqualified prohibition to begin with.
Um,
the Torah then also prohibits intermarriage with certain very specific
foreigners,
Moabites and ammonites specifically because of their cruel treatment of the
Israelites during their trip from Egypt to the promised land.
Egyptians are prohibited only to the third generation,
but there's no prohibition against marriage with other foreigners.
You know,
a Phoenician,
uh,
an Arab,
so long as they enter into the covenant of Gateway,
as long as they don't lead the Israelite partner into the worship.
Other gods,
the ration now for intermarriage prohibitions in the Pantry are always
behavioral,
right?
They're always moral.
If this person will lead you with straight with warrant practices,
that is prohibited.
But marriage into the group is not prohibited.
Indeed,
Israel's kings married foreign women regularly.
Many of the kings of Israel were themselves offspring of these foreign women.
They were still fully Israelite.
Israelite identity passed through the male line.
But Ezra who is protective of Israel's religious identity is zealous for the
Lord,
is wary of God's wrath.
He's interpreting and promulgating these prohibitions in such a way as to create
a general ban on intermarriage of any kind.
Israel mustn't make the same mistake twice.
Israelite identity is now made contingent in Ezra as view on the status of both
the mother and the father.
One is only an Israelite if one has both an Israelite mother and an Israelite
father,
both must be of the holy seed.
This is a phrase which is being coined now in Israel time and is now serving as
a rationale for intermarriage.
The ban on intermarriage.
It's not that a person is prohibited because they will lead to a straight to the
worship of what the gods.
That's something that can be corrected if the person in fact enters into the
religious community of Israel.
The rationale is that they just simply are not up holy seed and there's nothing
that you can do to change that.
So this becomes a permanent and universal band.
So that's the first very important thing that as or tries to do,
right,
the dissolution of marriage with foreign spouses and two to establish a blanket
universal ban on,
on intermarriage to make Israel identity dependent on the Israelite status,
the native Israelites status of both mother and father.
Second deed is the renewal of the Mosaic Covenant and this act is reported in
Nehemiah eight there's an extended public reading of the tour of Moses and
that's followed then by a renewal of the mosaic covenant.
When the seventh month arrived,
the Israelites being settled in their towns,
the entire people assembled as one man in the square before the Watergate and
they asked Ezra the scribe to bring the scroll of the teaching of Moses with
which the Lord had charged Israel.
On the first day of the seventh month,
Ezra the priest brought the teaching before the congregation,
men and women and all who could listen with understanding.
He read from it facing the square before the Watergate from the first light
until mid day to the men and the women.
And those who could understand the ears of all the people were given to the
scroll of the teaching.
The word here is Tara as her,
the scribes stood upon a wooden Torah tower made for the purpose as her open the
scroll and the sight of all the people for he was above all the people as he
opened it.
All the people stood up as you're blessed,
the Lord,
the Great God and all the people answered.
Amen.
With hands,
appraised the leaders and the Levi's explained the teaching to the people while
the people stood in their places.
They read from the scroll of the teaching of God translating it and giving the
sense so they understood the reading.
Apparently the assembled people no longer understood the classical Hebrew of the
Bible.
If it was formulated in that,
I mean,
what,
what he was actually,
what is this scroll?
I mean,
this is the first time now that we're hearing about the Torah as a scroll and
being read to people.
So,
um,
this is historically quite fascinating,
but the people don't seem to be able to understand it as ran.
His sister and his assistants are probably translating it into Aramaic,
which is now the Lingua Franca of the Persian empire,
giving the sense of the text perhaps as it's,
as it's being read,
we really can't be certain what it is that Ezra was presenting as the Torah of
Moses.
It may have been the pentitude basically in the form that we now have it.
Um,
both d and p are very strongly reflected in Ezra.
He quotes from them,
he refers to them and then interprets and applies them in new and interesting
ways.
And in any event,
this Torah was to become the basis and the standard with a lot of good,
heavy Persian imperial support for the Jewish community from that time forward
and at a festival celebration a few weeks later,
there was an additional public teaching of the law and a recital of Israel's
history that once again laid special emphasis on Israel's obligations,
what she owed to Yahweh.
The recitation of that history is found in the Hawaiian nine and again,
as an interpreter,
as an interpretation of the calamities that Israel had faced.
It's consistent with the earlier prayer of Ezra,
uh,
that I read.
God has withheld nothing from Israel,
yet Israel has to five God rebelled against him,
killed the prophets who had urged them to turn back to the covenant.
And God tolerated Israel sin as long as he possibly could.
But finally he had to punish her.
But even so in his great compassion,
God didn't abandoned Israel completely.
Verse 33 of this prayer then turns and addresses God.
Surely you are in the right with respect to all that has come upon us for you
have acted faithfully and we have been wicked.
So again,
this justification of God and blaming of the Israelites for all that has
befallen them and learning a lesson for that in the future.
No intermarriage.
All of this is but a prelude to the people's reaffirmation and renewed
commitment to the covenant.
And it's spelled out in great detail in Nehemiah 10 chapter 10 opens in view of
all this,
we make this pledge and put it in writing.
And then their follows the list of all the officials,
the Levites,
the priests,
the heads of the people.
And it says that all of these officials and leaders in conjunction join with the
people.
Verse 30 and 31 they joined with their noble brothers and take an oath with
sanctions to follow the teaching of God given through Moses,
the servant of God,
and to observe carefully all the commandments of the Lord,
our God,
his rules and laws.
Namely,
we will not give our daughters in marriage to the peoples of the land or take
their daughters for our sons.
So we then read the various obligations that the people are committing
themselves to.
And these include observance of the Sabbath Day in the sabbath year,
as well as supplying the needs of the upkeep of the temple.
But it's surely significant that the ban on intermarriage and the observance of
the Sabbath top the list,
right.
We are going to commit ourselves again to,
to God's teachings rules.
And laws.
Namely we won't intermarry and we'll observe the sabbath,
though these are are singled out as the top at the top of the list as central
covenantal obligations.
And chapter 13 describes Nehemiah's efforts to see that the people live up to
this pledge and he's he scurries around Jerusalem.
He's enforcing the cessation of work on the Sabbath.
He's persuading individuals to give up therefore and wives.
Ezra,
Nehemiah,
we're zealous in their promotion of the renewed covenant.
And in their view,
the centerpiece of the Covenant was the ban on intermarriage and the observance
of the Sabbath.
And it is interesting that these two phenomena in addition to circumcision,
uh,
will emerge as the three identifying features of a,
of a Jew.
In the ancient world,
when you look at external literature,
there were circumcised people.
There's one day of the week that they don't work and they don't marry outside
their group.
Those are the kinds of themes that you start to see in,
in writings of ancient Greeks and so on.
When they talk about this,
people as are,
Nehemiah's reforms can be seen as a direct response to the events of Israel's
history.
What's happened before just cannot be allowed to happen again.
And they view the tragic history as a cautionary tale.
It's calling upon the people to make the necessary changes to avoid a repeat
disaster.
There's only one way to guarantee that Israel will never again be destroyed.
She has to live up to the covenant.
She failed to honor in the past just to dead her,
dedicate herself to the continent.
And this time she has to be single minded in her devotion to God because history
has shown that God will punish faithlessness and betrayal.
Israel can't be led astray by the beliefs and practices of her neighbors.
And so a strict policy of separation has to be enforced if Israel is going to
finally be cured of the desire for idols.
And again,
it's interesting that in Jewish tradition,
the Jewish tradition is that the,
um,
uh,
the flirtation with idolatry which had plagued Israel and the first temple
period cease to exist in the second temple period.
Uh,
so again,
this is another area in which Jews earn for themselves a reputation in
antiquity.
They have a reputation for their strict monotheism,
the their scrupulous avoidance of foreign gods.
They will not bow down to another God.
There is this people that doesn't in a Mary,
they don't work one day a week and they won't bow down to our kings or to other
gods.
These are the kinds of things you find in these,
in writings in this period.
But Ezra and Nehemiah backed by Persian imperial authority help to create and
preserve,
create and preserve,
not just preserve,
create and preserve a national and religious identity for Jews at a precarious
time.
Their reforms were not universally welcomed,
um,
already even in the books of Ezra and Nehemiah,
uh,
which give a very sympathetic account of their work.
Obviously we can see rumblings and discontent.
Um,
there are other works that are going to express opposition to the separatism of
Ezra and Nehemiah.
Isaiah 56 verses one to seven.
I'm an interesting passage at states quite explicitly that foreigners have
joined themselves to God are welcome.
They're welcome in the temple.
They are welcome.
Even to minister before God,
there's a good deal of historical evidence for the assimilation of foreigners
within the Jewish community going on all the time.
Non Jews became Jews.
They married Jews.
Um,
we know of one family,
the [inaudible] family,
quite influential.
They were originally an ammonite family.
Now that is a group that is explicitly prohibited from entering the congregation
in Deuteronomy,
but this is a family that adopted Jewish identity became fully assimilated.
Um,
so clearly there's there,
there's great difference of opinion on this matter.
And in the last two lectures we're going to be focusing a lot on the diversity
of approaches to the whole question of Israelite Jewish identity and
relationship to the gentile world.
So although under Ezra the Torah became the official and authoritative norm for
Israel,
although under Ezra Judaism took the decisive step towards becoming a religion
of scripture,
you know,
based on this scriptural text,
this did not in itself result in a single uniform set of practices or beliefs.
Adopting the Torah as a communal norm simply meant that practices and beliefs
were deemed to be authentic to the degree that they accorded with the sense of
scripture and interpretation of scripture varied dramatically.
So that widely divergent groups now in the Persian period,
and as we move into the Hellenistic period,
widely divergent groups will claim biblical warrant for their specific practices
and beliefs.
So in short,
Ezra may have unified Israel around a common text,
but he didn't unify them around a common interpretation of that text.
Alright,
when we come back,
we'll be looking at about four more books,
all of which set up very interesting and different views on some of these basic
questions.